- I didn't know you were
coming out like this.
- You didn't?
- No they didn't tell me.
(audience cheers)
- I love this.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Oh my gosh I love this.
Wait, you made yours like
real sparkly and cute.
- I put on the sparkle.
- You are so cute.
- Sorry, I am like check it out.
- I love it. I love the sparkle.
You're the fancy Ghostbuster.
- I want to be the pop star Ghostbuster.
- It's like the Spice Girls,
there's different Ghostbusters.
- Exactly, we're finally
in a band together.
- I wanna be Athleisure Ghostbuster.
- Okay.
- That's our band.
- Yes
(audience laughs)
- So what's been your
favorite Halloween costume,
other than how fabulous
you look right now?
- Thank you so much, this is my faves.
You mean, in my entire life.
- Yes. Like in your life, like,
which one is your favorites.
- Oh man, um last year
it was Cindy Lou Who.
That was fun.
- Oh I love that.
- Yeah. My first like
professional makeup for Halloween,
but this year I'm doing this,
and I'm also gonna be Dr. Phil.
- Oh my
(Kelly laughing)
(crowd laughing)
- Check it out. It's
gonna be on my podcast.
I have on my bro called working on it and
I'm getting the, ball cap and everything.
I love my Doctor Phil.
- Oh, oh my God, a Texan
Oh my God. I love that,
that's your costume,
but you and you and Daryl went
to Halloween horror nights.
Okay. I've never done this.
- What?
- I know. Ariana keeps trying to,
- I go every ,yeah.
- She keeps trying to get me
to go, and I'm like, oh my God,
I'm so busy. Cause I'm terrified.
- Just go with a friend.
- I know I'm telling her I'm gonna go.
She wants me to go, and I'm
just like, look, we can all go,
but I get to be in the
middle. So that way,
- [Meghan] Yes.
- If anything attacks
us, I get attacked last.
- [Meghan] Yes yes .
- Okay. Yeah.
I'm that person?
- I have been like 7 years in a row.
- Are You serious?
- Oh my God.
- [Kelly] Who gets more
scared? You or Darryl.
- Me
- [Kelly] You?
- Yeah, I scream. I'm loud.
- [Kelly] You scream?
- Yes.
- [Meghan] Yeah. It's dangerous for us .
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Meghan] yeah
- [Kelly] You all are adorable.
Oh I like this guy ,
that's creepy as hell.
- Come right up to you.
- Nope.
- Yeah
- They come right up to you.
I cannot be held
accountable for my physical.
- Yeah yeah
(Meghan giggling)
- [Kelly] I will punch someone. Yeah.
Cause it's just a naive .
I'm like get away from us why are you,
stranger danger. I shouldn't go.
- We should go.
(Crowd applauding)
Welcome back to our Halloween Celebration,
Meghan Trainor and I are
here, busting ghosts.
Cause our Ghostbusters
afterlife hour continues.
That was like, we were just talking
(loud screaming)
(Spooky haunting music)
What? What the hell?
Oh yeah, where is , where is Winston?
(crowd laughing)
Winston is gone.
- I'm trying to be chilling it .
- I hate being scared.
I don't know (laughs).
- I was like I don't think she knows.
- I have peed a little. It's fine.
Oh, I don't like being scared. I am fine .
Okay so as I was saying,
I am gonna come back,
I am coming back.
As I was saying that was a look at
Meghan show Top Chef family style
new episode drop Thursdays,
(Crowd applauding)
on Peacock.
So um, what's your show about?
- Oh, that show is about cooking
and it's a competition show.
- [Kelly] Are you a cook? Do you cook?
- No, I'm terrible at cooking.
- [Kelly] Oh me too.
- I don't know why I got
the job, but I love it.
And I got to eat and it's,
it's with family members,
so it's like, a kid from
9 to 15 years old with a,
with a family members.
So it's really cute.
- [Kelly] Well that ties with you,
cause you like working with family.
- Yes I was like, I am a family,
yeah my whole family is here today,
and I am trying to learn
how to cook for my son,
so I gotta eat amazing
food everyday and judge it,
and I made friends, and
Marcus is my new best friend.
- [Kelly] I love Marcus.
- Yeah it's the best time ever.
- Yeah. That's so cool I
mean it kinda does fit in
cause it got the family aspect.
- [Meghan] Yeah
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I think it's so cool
your family is so tight.
That's amazing.
Not everyone has that.
And it's amazing, you are still
tight after Covid (laughs).
Like bit locked up.
- Oh yeah. Closer, we are even closer now.
- Well last time we were here,
you announced that you were
having a boy, so congrats.
- Yes.
- So it was a rocky birth
right, It ended up being .
- Well he was breached, so
you know he was sideways
and we had to do C-section
and I was just like ,
oh I wasn't ready for this
and he came out with
some breathing problems,
but after like 5. So I
met him over FaceTime.
- [Kelly] Oh..
- [Meghan] But, after 5
days we got to take him home
and he is so healthy and
happy now, but it was
- That skin to skin time .
- I didn't get it, I didn't
get for the first like 2 days.
- Oh I will cry right now.
- Yes, I was like,
it was really hard and I was like .
- [Kelly] Oh my god like
emotionally, I would faint.
- I only got to see him over
FaceTime and I was like,
I mean ,I guess,
thank god I have an iPhone
or something ,but like .
- [Kelly] Yeah
- [Meghan] miss him.
- [Kelly] And like miracle
that they get to help you.
- [Meghan] Yeah .
- [Kelly] That's amazing ,but
man that skin to skin time,
even afterwards like I am just like
Lay on me .Lay on me.
I was like I want you.
- Now I don't let go cause I
am like know what it is like .
- Yeah they are so cute and snugly.
- And he is finally in
a age where he is like
get off me .
I am like no.
- You are like prepare yourself for life.
- Yeah, prepare yourself.
- I mean forever.
- (giggling)
- You easily talked
about your post baby body
in People magazine. So things change.
And I know that happens,
but you did say though,
that you're really on top of
it. I think that's amazing.
I am still is in my baby weight.
(Kelly laughing)
(crowd laughing)
- It's you're stunning.
- Yeah I'm.
I did not go right back.
- It's not really that hard.
- I lost all my baby weight,
and then some which is incredible.
- [Kelly] That's awesome .
- Yeah(crowd applauding)
cause I was working hard, like
- I'm not willing to do that. Quite yet.
- Role of Top chef. It was like,
I got up at 5 and worked out
and focus on my nutrition.
I've been like,
for my kid, like I,
I went on 45 minute walks with
him every day and I was like,
I'm gonna work on my health
so that we can run together.
You know.
- Oh But I've never got
really depressed about that.
I think it's such a ma-, we're magical.
We make humans. That's amazing.
(crowd applauding)
- Amazing.
- We make Central nervous system.
- Yeah
- Like, that's incredible, and brains.
And like, we're like, I don't know .
- And you truly I mean, for me,
I'm already like, let's go again.
Like let's make,
- I love that.
- Even like, no matter how
like scary the birth was
or anything on like 5 more at least.
- Oh, I love, well you love
you are such a big family,
and y'all are so tight. That's why.
- More.
- That's yeah great,
like oh my god (laughs)
that was like, wheyyy.
no, it is fun to have them all the same.
Then at least you get all the diapers,
everything done all at once.
- That's what I am saying.
Let's get it going .
- It is interesting Like two years later,
like, Oh cool. All this is coming back.
So on another subject.
Cause there is more to
life than that, about it.
(giggling)
So your brothers live with you,
which I find interesting
because does that get awkward?
Are you ever like you stay over there?
- We're very close or very open.
- I am very close with my like sister,
but I don't know if we should be
like living together.
- I think we just always have, like, we,
I started in California.
Like I lived at Park La
Brea with my older bro.
- [Kelly] So you don't know anything?
- I don't know anything else
and I wouldn't want it any other way.
Sometimes when we're, if we
fight he'll threaten me like,
well I'm moving out and
I'm like, don't do it.
- Oh my God. I lived with my brother once.
And if he threatened that I'd be like,
Cause I'm like,
cause it's like,
sometimes he would bring
girls home and I'm like,
- That's a thing.
- This is a different thing
- Because it's like you're in the
public eye. And like, it
just depends who it is.
You're bringing into my home.
- Well my bro, my bro is
smart enough he tests them.
So like one, one girl came over,
- (Kelly Laughing and clapping)
- One girl came over and she
started filming the entire
backyard and tagged us and he's like
done, like never again.
- What a way to pick the weeds.
- Yeah. Yeah. It's nice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.